yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby back
back in Boys Are Back In Town Boys Are
Back In Town you and I didn't really
wish each other a Merry Christmas or a
happy New Year because we don't do that
kind of stuff I don't have any good
friends text me that stuff some business
people text me which is nice but as far
as friends friends no we don't you do we
even do happy birthday not really if you
see like happy birthday man but
really hey hold on can we no hold on
what do you steal those from Oprah okay
now hold on these were oh I know where I
know where those I I've been in the
hospital last8 days 24/7 did you steal
those from the nurses at the nicku now
hold on Brandon those are the Gaylord
fuer special I don't know I think these
are super streamlined and they look
dangerously neutral hey look at me yeah
they look so gay hey look at me those
look like you're confused about your
pronouns well now that's different now
maybe they look a little gender neutral
that's what I was saying they might oh
you know what those are those are the
female or male shoes yeah and these are
the on it's for everybody they came with
my Tesla my Tesla 3 I knew it I knew it
yeah they're the cuck Sho and so here we
are and that's why us cucks are us and
that's why I keep my little feet like
that and I can do that no seriously what
are you doing all right look they were
given to me by somebody for Christmas
and I find them very comfortable and I
actually thought you'd be like those are
cool KS no I don't no KS it's we were
talking start I looked down went whoa I
looked at them and I went maybe I'll
wear these to see what brenon thinks
maybe he'll think they're cool kicks but
they're not no they're like nurses and
then they're like this weird off brand
and they're also super cheap I guess
they're made of recyclable materials oh
no yeah way too they're a little too
comfortable you know what I mean pillows
on my feet hope it doesn't rain yeah
those things are going to melt like a
fake Rolex well I you know when I wear
them I will say this and this I'm just
being totally honest when I wear them
they do feel great on my feed but I have
a crazy crazy overwhelming craving for
[__] makes sense as a straight man the
good thing is is every woman dries up
when she sees you wear these will dry
vaginas up those are Crocs I would
rather you wear Crocs well these these
these
shoes say they scream um I'll never I'll
never retaliate no matter what you do to
me those scream whatever yeah whichever
way the wind blows no opinions here yep
yep yep those they're they're I'm I'm
I'm on the fence those scream I can hurt
your feelings easily that's what those
are yeah starting the new year
offes here's the thing when you get
older when you're older it's about
Comfort it's about Comfort it's about do
my toes spread out cuz I got kids now
almost four children you know one on the
way 57 in January you you think I care
I'm old bro old but still going at it
still going at it made some dietary
changes oh God New Year same BR no no no
no no it's been going on new year new me
no no no it's been going on 2024 are you
just figuring it out at your age well
Daddy did uh how was your break though
[__] your dad so I went I went I was in
Naples had a blast see boy alligator
hunting did I see Eric did I see Eric
and austo at virgin the best
restaurant best restaurant in North
America I I'm right with you on that and
I spend I spent all my time there did
you go to the car place I told you to I
that's the one thing I didn't do because
I they let you in godam I told them I
said he's a friend of mine he reached
out to me and I forgot I actually
totally forgot to talk to him because I
had to go shark
fishing now I'll show you the footage on
shark fishing nothing happened okay
here's the thing about shark love Shar
whenever you do something with sharks
nothing happens so we go out there and
apparently there are 1,000lb 1300 lb
Tigers Bull and even great whites which
I didn't know off right off of Florida
that's a unicorn but sure it's a unicorn
but but they're out there so what we get
out there and um you're in a boat we're
in a boat like big boat or uh no no no
sir it's a it's a small boat it's a
small boat it's a little fishing boat
and he says to me you know I had to have
a conversation about red tide red tide
which is algae oh yeah and how it killed
off everything cuz it sucks all the out
of the water even Dolphins died so I'm
like all right yeah and then he goes
it's all the runoff from all the
development I'm like [__] runoff so
I'm having a Florida conversation
[__] run off all this development we
got to do something and they're training
the Everglades you know so don't get me
start on ling fish that's right they'll
tell you that oh this place is loaded
with standard Florida conversation with
a Floridian who knows better and I'm and
I'm trying to be cool I'm trying to have
something with him there and then he
says uh he starts to Chum the the water
now now the way you chum water is uh
You' think it's like just big slops of
blood fish it's dried blood it's dried I
know it's powder well that's on a budget
looks like gunpowder but that's on a
budget they did this on a budget well
guess sharks Daddy yeah I guess no no I
guess it works because it's dried blood
that you then take a scoop and and it
and it you know know what he did he
chummed the water with Beyond burger
meat well that might I like I don't know
why they're not showing up well here's
thing he said the the current is not
taken hey you got to hustle no hold on
you got to hustle hold on be quiet he he
jum the water with I promise no no there
it is there it is now here's the thing I
uh you chum the water all right and what
happens is as you chum it you want to
make sure that you chum it when the tide
is going out so it brings that scent
from miles and then the big boys come
back in but they the sharks are too
smart they know it's not real [__] well
you know I don't know what they think
just I just know that somehow the tide
wasn't going out it didn't work now
here's the other thing you got to
understand you got to you got to I he
had a bunch of shrimp and I said what's
that for he goes well we got to catch a
larger fish to catch a larger fish so
it's a twep process you understand you
got to get yourself a a seab bass or
some [__] whatever it is then cut him so
the big fish out yeah you just you you
you you you hook him so the fish is
flopping I assume he did that after he
ched the water with the Beyond burger
meat yeah we caught one caught one very
small looking fish and he went there you
go and we hooked that with a giant hook
this guy hustled you and that's not what
it looked like and that's we shot it out
there we shot it out there and uh so you
didn't see one shark well I I I spent my
time uh with the shrimp still sir I
spent my time with the shrimp now I hate
fishing no I'm sorry hate is too weak a
word see I like it I love it yeah I
[__] hate it that's cuz you're in one
place at one time you can't you have ADD
also the the goals showed up SE gos GS
showed up and they were just like woohoo
I'm going to eat all your shrimp every
time I'd cast they they make life
difficult yeah now I'm fighting with no
Dolphins cuz theyo dophins zero do zero
Dolphins so anyway that was that then I
went then I went gator hunting now gator
hunting we were yeah gator hunting was
on a farm I don't I don't kill the
that's not hunting it's on it's on a
farm uh well it was an old gator farm
that's what they tell you yeah so
they're there now here's the other thing
stock it with with with wild boar well
wild pig you know what I mean yeah pigs
now hold on now here's the thing about
here's the thing about no no here's the
thing when you have a bunch of pools
with a bunch of
gators okay the and then you release a
bunch of hogs what happens is the Hogs
go water I'm hot that looks that looks
like soft wonderful mud and they get in
the old mud and they go I love muds cuz
I'm a little piggy Pig and I'm going to
drink some water and the gator goes oh
now that's adorable I'm going to kill
you and what the gator does is it grabs
him it's just like fish in a barrel
grabs that hog and here's the kicker
here's the kicker it drowns it and then
it lets it purify it'll let it it'll rot
it that's what they do with hum too yeah
for two weeks at least so now you got
it's called wet a now you got a yeah now
you got it's called wet aging now you
got a [__] hog sitting in water with
flies all over it that doesn't smell you
dry aging yeah it's wet aging wet Aging
for and that smells great that smells
really great smelled like a fart the
entire time I caught a [__]
six-footer maybe a five-footer I saw the
video Yeah well that one was 10 that was
a big boy but the one the little one
that we were going to eat I get on it
and it just taken a bite out a pig and
its breath smelled like a [__] open
grave you know want any part of that
[__] so let me straight you went you
went shark hunting no sharks uh you went
alligator hunting but went to a farm
where they couldn't run and um well it
used to be a farm this now it's now it's
a
farm well at least you got some content
out of it sure did Bren and did did you
eat any alligator I did eat the
alligator and I'll tell you something
Eric's Chef prepared it I swear to God
Bubba I swear to God ever had I've had
it it's so so lean though it's like it's
like better chicken a little chewier but
chicken aren't fat either but you've
never seen a fat alligator dude you
never seen they're rocked like eating
Dwayne well we so you know you catch the
gator right you you toss it out there
and you roll you reel it back in and
what happens is it gets caught you you
just try to catch it with the hook
anywhere on its body sure so we we hook
this 10-footer they are about 500 lb
that's that that that's impossible to
shoot them in the head no we didn't kill
it we didn't kill it the guy jumps on
the on his back and then it it it it
grabs its snout holds its snout down
then you grab the snout and pull a head
totally up toward you somehow that calms
him down and you you do this your boor
in Florida or yeah well I want to shoot
an I want to get some action content oh
gotcha you know what saying bro I live
on the and then uh for the Tik Tok yeah
but then I had great shows every show
was almost just totally packed cuz
people thought oh you know it's
Christmas no they all come out cuz
they're all there and then I went to
Charlotte had a blasted the comedy zone
that was interesting um I don't know did
you do anything for New Year's uh no
brenon I was on stage as I've been for
the past 20 years I was on stage every
New Year this the first year I passed
remember every year I tell you I text
you right after I'm like I'm never doing
New Year's again this is the first year
I stuck to my guns right right I was
asleep by 10: with a kid I was in bed
nothing wrong with that you didn't want
to see the ball drop you didn't want to
see the ball drop and blow a kazoo yeah
don't yeah with a paper hat on the whole
New Year's thing I don't give a [__]
yeah I uh for me it's just another year
I'm closer to death oh yeah you're
getting up there I'm getting up there
buddy 2024 woo feeling good though today
today I went to a place called Fountain
life where um they this the future it's
The Cutting Edge of science technology
I'm out no they gave me every scan you
can think of so I'm going to get my
results in about four weeks we'll see
how close daddy is really to death I
mean I'm talking about looking at your
I'm talking about taking iodine and they
look they get in that [__] they they
didn't get in your [__] but they do a
full body MRI count and I got to get a
colopy go in your booty hole you got to
go do a colonoscopy I've had one of
those I'm good you got to get that ass
though got to get in the ass got to get
in that ass is that is that are you the
ass come in you come in science dude
with a rubble glove got to get in your
ass now yeah it's like a tree it's like
the rings on a tree you not done you're
too young but they do a deck Deca Scan
they do a they do all kinds of [__] just
to tell you how long you're going to
live like the
living like he is they want to see the
soft plaque in your heart and [__] the
only thing I do wrong only thing is I
take a little too much saturated fat
probably a little too much a little too
much like your height and weight dude
you be around for a long you're so
skinny yeah skinny people live forever
I'm pretty healthy I have a lot of
energy I have shitloads of energy yeah
you know I I really do like uh Rogan was
talking about me with Derek from more
plates more dates and he was alluding to
the fact that guys like me don't have
the energy he has I have all the energy
I'll put my energy he saying guys like
you yeah he said because he he wants
because he said is Brian K on trt yet
and and Joe said no he says
testosterone's high and which it is but
I'm going to get another read of my
testosterone so the past two
testosterone I don't give [__] what your
testosterone says I mean Joe included I
don't know anyone with more energy than
you Joe said you don't have energy yeah
yeah well he thought I would he he was
like some of these guys break down after
doing two shows a night come hang with
me does it come hang with me I'll sh
you're the worst example for I'm the
worst example I'll work out for two
hours that's like looking at DK mat metf
and being like dude just eat gummy bears
in one meal a day you're going to look
like that I'm the wrong guy I'm the
wrong guy awful examp I'm the wrong guy
to [__] try to match energies with
you're not Terri idea I'm a wrong guy in
endurance or any of that it's going to
be a bad it's going to be a long day for
you that's weird R had all his friends
well he just well I think he was talking
more about how he has a lot of people
that he tries to he he's just a big
believer and on support especially as
you get older which he's probably right
about which believe me I'm I'm around
the corner I don't think you need it
though why [__] with it I talk to those
I talk to team of scientist you know why
all Joe myself all of us are on it cuz
we need it yeah you don't need it no I
really just don't I don't talk to my
wife you know what I mean chin hey chin
you know what I mean right you mean chin
you know I'm sorry chin how you doing
I'm doing all right Jen you're all quiet
man is here's all [__] up today yeah
why it's like a sponge are you a little
depressed usually like are you okay not
depressed but obviously I'm a little sad
why you a little sad you guys want to
discuss it now oh yeah let's talk about
oh yeah George yeah let's talk about
George for a sec guys so there's been a
lot of
misinformation George did not get fired
no George was asked we you need somebody
with more experience in right now as
thick boys expanding into different
areas yeah we need have like full
producer not 22y old right and so
everybody loves George so what what I
think you did was offered him a
different Lex who runs the company Lex
run CF offered him something else you
you are not a good person for that job
to go and even talk to George because
you're very attached to George
emotionally I'm going to speak for
Brennan for a second guys you're very
attached to him you're terrible at any
kind of any kind of repositioning firing
or anything you're the worst you're the
[__] worst and so having we know this
about you so we have other people that
actually run the mechanics and
day-to-day operation of thick Boy Yes
okay I'm I'm just speaking and you tell
me when I'm wrong so George is somebody
all of us here care about and and right
now I think you guys offered George
something else with where he doesn't
have to cuz now he's killed himself
coming in every day yeah so he doesn't
want a different role his thing was it's
not that he doesn't want to be here but
he has other opportunities which I
fac he has two good ones which I helped
him facilitate so I understand like if
he if he if those don't work out he can
come back here you know that it's always
open I love George I talked to George
probably more than anybody in here
besides you I talk to him too and I'm
we're gonna if I can help him game plan
I said dud this why people got you know
how far Georgie has this my conversation
with today me and him talked in person
how far Georgie has come you got think
about it I Met George when he has 450
lbs on King in the sting sent in a
submission CU my goal is to get down to
190 blah blah blah I'm a thick boy I
said Georgie you get down to 190 I'll
fly you here live in studio year later
calls in he's 190 I fly him in he's such
a good if you ever meet George can't
help but love the kid fly him in here I
love him I go dude come to San Antonio
with you ever stay in a nice hotel never
cool first time on a plane too fly him
to San Antonio put him up at our
favorite hotel hotel Emma give him the
presidential suite he's living like a
king him on stage and then I was like
can't stop here dude I'll find a job for
you that's you that's you that's you you
you you know yeah that's you and but so
he went from zero skills to he can edit
now he can cut Clips he can do social
media he's problem with you here's the
problem with you you get you get
emotionally attached to everybody
correct I shouldn't be running business
I also don't hire and I I I think that
is a liability for you because sometimes
s you got uh yeah I have a bad reader
well it's not that you're a bad reader
dude you're just very optimistic some
jobs if you're running this a company
you you are going to need a 30-year-old
person who has a lot of experience to
run [__] and you have to be a [__]
background check and yeah but you also
have to be the kind of guy that is like
people that run a business are way more
ruthless than you they go you it's not
working you got to get out of here
that's the way I'm not like that not
like that not that let me just tell you
about Brenan so just so people know the
the number of people that we had who we
all love and they were all great but
there were things sometimes where this
person I'm not talking about George in
this case I'm talking about in our in
the 12 years we've been here there were
I think we've had
probably I think eight or nine real
discussions about you calling me and
saying I don't know what to do with this
person they're not doing their job and I
and I and it's it's driving me crazy
because I'm paying them a fortune I
always a [__] fortune and I would be
like okay and then what would we always
say what would we always say uh you
finish my sentence you would go yeah but
you're not going do anything no I'd say
and you know what we're going to do
about this absolutely You' say
absolutely nothing we we leave them on
board for another year at least until it
gets so toxic or whatever whatever the
case you know and that's not the way to
run a business right and so we have a
22-year-old who we all care about who we
are who we want to win and he will win
and I'll do what I can you know to help
him gain Geor has a great resume now his
skills and he's also a great kid and
also he came in today to tell me and did
a great job here by the way let's put
that on record but uh he came in today
me and him talked in person just to tell
me like if it's going to be a part-time
thing like I'd rather just go somewhere
full-time I was I get that dude I get
that you know yeah love Georgie well
that's that's a win that's the goal to
go from here to and it's hard you know
he's 22 he's never this first job really
yeah so he's coming straight out 22 from
his background so it's like he just
getting more experience that's all it is
well I mean yeah I I told him when I
talked to him I said this is all this is
good it's that Jo o willik thing good
good
now opportunity to to even get better
and build a bigger skill set look when I
as an actor um I had seven yeses in my
[__] career and everything else was a
no and what I had an acting teacher say
this to me said yeah you know oh this
woman was crying cuz she hadn't worked
and said he goes yeah it's real hard
it's a bit right it's a [__] um here's
what you got to look at when you go in
for a job an acting job or any [__]
job and you're interviewing for a
company take this uh mindset they have a
problem that problem is they need
someone to fill a need fill a gap be the
solution to that problem if you come in
and you're the actual solution to that
problem and you're solving problems they
didn't even see like Chin Chin is a good
example chin came in I don't know how
many years ago and he put uh something
over around your neck right he he was
wearing a he was wearing like a hard
drive and he goes I'm your guy this is
what I can do oh got at and Chin Chin is
chin is a guy who no matter what any any
crisis we've been through whatever it is
this [__] would always say to me
Brian stay positive Brian stay positive
Brian stay positive or or just he's the
rock he's the [__] rock no matter
what always here Dwayne Johnson he's you
know what chin you're the Asian Dwayne
Johnson thank you only not as thick
that's sick probably better heart not
not a better heart I mean he Dwayne like
he's physically his heart juice running
through it he's pushing things yeah God
bless him yep I love that guy yeah I
know love Georgie so I wish there was a
cooler story for you guys but yeah
that's it George is good yeah chin sad
chin how you feel what do you have to
say about it that's just sad you know it
got attached to him so yeah of course we
all did yeah oh yeah yeah yeah but he'll
be we we'll bring him back in oh yeah
yeah periodically he's going to be
around La for a while is he yeah good
that's
important um anyway all right so uh
let's take I'm going to cry let's take a
break let's take a let's take a 30
second uh weep break and take a hot weep
break how about uh changing lanes how
about the are you familiar with the
Gypsy
Rose um the let me fill you in okay let
me fill you in so she uh had a mother
she was a young child her mom uh what do
they call it muncher muncher muncher by
proxy so her mom would give her
medication feed her brain all this
[__] that she's sick zero problems
she thought she had leukemia shaved her
head forced to be in a wheelchair
basically a form of torture yeah do she
had to eat through a feeding tube took
all her teeth out to get a free house
and all this stuff so she does since
she's a little kid her mom did this to
her it's all fake she don't have any of
this doctor was starting to get privy to
it so the mom's super strict with her
forced her to sit in a wheelchair and
even at the house she's like Mom I can
walk though she's like nope you got to
stay in the wheelchair so think about a
little kid Jesus she meets his boyfriend
she's like this is what my mom's doing
to him I'm actually not sick I can't
stand this anymore you should kill her
for me he goes deal stabs the mom 14
times she gets arrested of course she
just got out of prison she has 6 million
followers the reason I tell this story
is cuz I think she kill your mom to sell
more tickets yes that's a good call uh I
don't think she should have gone to jail
I think so destroyed but here's the so
it's premeditated because she text her
boyfriend for like months to talk him
into killing her mom so you can't plead
Insanity right cuz it's premeditated but
the mom it's a sign of it's a some sort
of torture right of course but I think
the the court saw that so they gave her
10 years she got out and eight can I the
boyfriend the boyfriend that killed the
mom got life the boyfriend going to
killed the mom got life now she was like
cool thanks for doing my dirty work I'm
going to go meet this other dude and get
married now so the guy who killed it I
mean really is in the tank right now
he's pretty sad yeah and that's the guy
she married this is the guy that killed
her that was the guy with that sick
haircut both of them oh no that's her
there that's her on the left that's him
on the right very tough to tell the
difference but that's her on the left
that's him on the right the mom would
shave her head cuz she said she had
cancer she was destroyed she was
destroyed and her mother's
uh should be in my opinion I'm not
shedding tears that her mom was killed
but that's you still can't do things out
now should the should the boyfriend who
was talked into killing the mom get life
um I don't know I I don't know these
details I don't know this is obviously a
young boy I don't know how old he was
and he's obious 17 maybe yeah so brain's
not developed you know I don't believe
taking a child who does something
horrific and putting him in jail forever
how horrific but yeah you know you might
have sociopath but he it sounds to me
like he was just trying to I also think
they're both on the Spectrum he's
definitely on the Spectrum yeah that's
what you get look at scumbag there look
at her no that's that's the handsome mom
there yeah yeah she's awful is she Pat
from sat Night Live well she's just a
horrible human being um isn't that crazy
though yeah it's it's the worst kind of
crime those kinds of things but um I
don't know man the life imprisonment for
the I don't think she should have done
time I don't I think that that is a a
form of self-defense or I don't know
weird right you think yeah put her in a
put her in psychiatric she's 32 now oh
he's 20 okay 23 too old a little too old
little too old he should have known
better mental issues too right here I'm
sure he does he loves yeah I'm telling
you if you watch like anything on him
you're like oh this kid's not all there
yeah he's not all there of course so
maybe he's a threat to society that's
why they did it I don't know is it weird
yeah it's it's that gray area of the law
because if it came out and we said yeah
she was beating her relentlessly since
she was a kid you like oh God man hell
yeah kill her but it's a different form
of torture I can see that kid being a
good kid saying I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna take out a monster and her mom was
a monster so this kid killed a monster
correct so when you kill monsters it all
depends on context doesn't it it all
depends on context but like when
soldiers take out terrorists we don't
consider murderers that's right yeah
they're hero so so but that that woman
might be worse a lot terrorist she's a
monster and so um monsters should die or
at least like pedophile same thing yeah
keep them like if you took got a
pedophile would be celebrating them
right but that's but they still lock
them up she's every bit as
worse as a pedophile probably let's say
you wore those shoes right and they
lower them in to being gay then you kill
all these pedophiles these are are you
saying these are pedophile shoes dude so
much yeah these are well they're they're
yeah I don't know neutral I feel like
these are male nurse shoes I feel like I
could get away with being a male nurse
so in some ways I could be heroic maybe
saing people but I'm saying if you
killed a bunch of pedophiles you're
still getting life in prison even though
you're like these are terrible people
man it doesn't
matter the way the court system works
they're not going to they're like we
don't care yeah if you're like hey the
the you know the government let them out
early the J Judicial System let them out
that you got life and you go and kill
five pedophiles like horrific pedophiles
you would still get life yeah you would
because right but no because you have to
run the way you run a society is you
cannot have Vigilantes and you cannot
have people who do what's called
extrajudicial killings no matter how
Justified you can't run a society like
that you cannot take quote unquote the
law into your own hands that that's why
we have laws you can't create a bunch of
Batman no you can't it would be although
in La you're basically going to have to
be Batman to survive you see our boy
from
90210 yes yeah you got attacked by that
weird gay biker gang yeah was a scooter
the little bikes what happened to him is
he okay can we take a little break dude
let's take a little break buddy let's
take a little break cuz speaking of
taking a break I've been taking a break
off touring but I pick it up we're
talking end of January I start January
25th in uh Nashville one night only at
zany then the 26th and 27th I'm in
Austin Texas Vulcan gas company yes sir
I'm going to be this well this Tom
tonight tomorrow the next day we're
talking about Mike comedy club in San
Diego California that's January 4
January 5 January 6 um come get some CB
Live January 19
2021 that's in Phoenix Arizona come get
some of that brian.com for tickets and
Louisville Kentucky after that dud this
episode of fire and the kid is brought
to you by Progressive Insurance most of
you listening right now you're probably
multitasking yep you're listening to us
you're on the phone you're texting you
might be driving Hopey not taxing
exising yeah maybe grocery sh shopping
getting that thick ass ready but if
you're not in some kind of moving
vehicle there's something else you can
be doing right now getting an auto quote
from Progressive Insurance it's easy you
could save money by doing it right from
your phone and by the way when you
switch to Progressive a lot of times
drivers save nearly $750 on average and
autoc customers qualify for an average
of seven discounts discounts for having
multiple vehicles on your policy being a
homeowner and more so just like your
favorite podcast Progressive will be
with Q 24/7 365 days a year so you're
protected no matter what so you can
multitask right now quote your car
insurance at progressive.com to join the
over ready for this number 28 million
drivers trust Progressive yeah
Progressive Casualty Insurance company
and Affiliates uh uh is that casualty
all right uh national average 12 month
savings of
$744 by new customer surveyed who saved
with Progressive between June 2022 and
may 2023 potential savings will vary of
course but discounts not available in
all states and situations Progressive
he's fine he's fine he said his daughter
was in the car oh man 10-year-old was in
the car man so messed up I think it
looks like he fought he fought the guy
for a little while then he kind of ran
away but then they
all my favorite is the guy that goes for
the sweep ready for this look at the guy
in the blue look
whoop
keep your hands he does a pretty good
job your hands up yeah he's a big strong
kid come on Ian it's probably my age but
here's what worries me his daughter's
still in the car you guys yes like if
something happens to him what happens to
her in the car it's tough he probably
did some and then caught traffic okay
there there he is he actually attacked
the guy first yeah but the guy did some
to the guy shattered his windshield
that's why he's doing this well so
there's more footage that just came up
recently it looks like he did just from
this footage it looks like he started
the fight but I thought they broke his
windshield they did they did eventually
no I thought before that's why he's
fighting him see his car right
here so that should be his car here
where's his car yeah
yeah so he comes
out okay well but I don't know what
happened before that I knowa so
something could have happened before
that's the video I need to see maybe
someone bumped him you never know I I I
uh I've I've hung out with him a couple
times back in the day slight Flags yeah
I I he was I was so blown away with how
funny he was and how cool he was he's a
[__] hilarious guy really good guy
hasn't worked much though as an actor
right he's getting that 90210 residual
check I know how much that is but he's
in shark NATO too right that did really
well he was in what shark NATO how dare
you it did it was a funny thing a a very
he's a very funny guy and uh and a
really yeah he's a cool guy up watching
him but funny like he'll crack you up I
know he keep saying that but he uh I I
want to see what happened there's no way
he just got out and pushed him because
they were surrounding his car they had
to do something before that's such a
weird biker
gang like look at their motorcycles dude
dude I saw a biker gang I I was watching
this bike gang s was like harassing this
dude he's in a Range Rover he goes cool
story I'm an SUV
k k runs over like six of them but then
traffic goes and then he's as dead stop
oh Bubba they get a hold of him and it's
did they hurt Rodney King sty he K
opposite yeah did he kill the the bikers
I I don't know if he killed them oh he
he ran over he ran over in their bikes
no no but then then they then traffic
was like you're going to have to sit
tight for a little bit and they went oh
we got them so they took their helmets
and Bash his windows in then drag him
out of the car and it's like 20 biker
gang dudes stomping this yeah you don't
want to be doing that to a biker gang
that's if you want Rush Traer gang don't
run over three of their members but also
don't do it in LA rush hour traffic cuz
you can't go anywhere do it in Texas or
Oklahoma where there's open road daddy
like I run you over my demon 170 you
ain't catching me dude you ain't
catching Daddy come on now hey on now oh
but they'll but the cops will just Trace
you back when you oh no you haven't
looked at the newsl you in La the cops
do nothing sir they don't do a lot you
know what they did with these guys
absolutely look into it first of all if
you got yourself if you got your helmet
on you're fine just keep your helmet on
and zip off they're not going to bother
for the biker gangs yeah not going to
bother unless they did catch that guy in
Philadelphia who jumped on the woman's
car and shattered the window with a kid
in the back they got him yeah they got
him because especially I think a lot of
I think fan I think OT people R it on
yeah Philly don't mess around La
nobody's really
you don't do that to a woman and and and
pulled a gun on her yeah [__] she
stuck up for herself that's Mama Bear
coming out yeah but that that that
coward oh dude if I if I see Hell's
Angels I I take a left turn yeah I don't
keep going the same direction I'll go
around yeah well there's the Hell's
Angels Mongols um there's another group
called Loki the Loki I can't remember
they're they're no joke man you don't
don't don't I told you had a bunch of
biker gangs at my show at Laugh Factory
and I was like oh boy they were so cool
oh yeah like dude we bet all your shop
show pics like don't kill me well those
guys those guys respect the fighters man
they were cool yeah Banditos the Mongols
yeah you don't want Hell's Angels yeah
pagans Mong the pagans that's who I
think I saw in in
uh you don't want to mess with any of
those but the Mongols and Hell Mongols
are in torly known as the most violent
and then Hell's Angels are just they're
the Coca-Cola biker gangs they just they
created a business their merch nuts
these are the list this is a list of out
law motorcycle clubs I just talked toot
let me see the list of Outlaw motorcycle
clubs obviously CU you can't call them
gangs they're called clubs piece of [__]
I think the Mongols are are the uh most
violent they're the they're the Latin
equivalent though because hell Angels
only has white guys I think no it's not
true okay I don't know want to go
through this
69ers they have a gang Bandidos black
Devils Black pistons and they're just in
Germany
Brother Speed the [__] motorcycle
club well Denmar I wish we got a little
more creative but yeah no these are I'm
talking about American ones they got
real dope names though you're crazy if
you don't think they appreciate my
new this list too long right let's be
honest it's Hell's Angels it's Mongols
and it's like the pagans those I don't
think it's you know those are the guys
oh the nomads mob
[__] yeah these are all guys in
other countries I don't care about the
guys they're here it's around the world
I'm talking about the guys who are in
the US they're pagans again pecker Woods
in Santi California P pissed off
Bastards of Bloomington that's dude
whoever's their graphic designers are
lit dude the merch is so dope with the
jean jackets I want one so bad yeah I
don't know what I have to do to earn
that but not you got to be part of that
group
Sons of
Satan yeah son oh the Vos is who I talk
to the Vos that's who I regarded as one
of the largest most powerful 1ent bik
gangs in the United States yeah the Vos
those are my fans those guys out let me
see the Vos those were my boys dude I've
seen those guys um yeah those [__]
dudes I've seen at the logo look at the
craftmanship lit dude yeah don't [__]
around I saw a bunch of those guys uh in
Vegas and they were kind of like just
all around me and I was like all right
don't swerve do you know how much fun
they must have they're Outlaws bro they
are outlaws they must have so much fun
stressful but fun yeah you seen Son of
Anarchy at that dude he's not [__]
around well he's sure's not [__] just
big men who are very comfortable with
violence that's what they do
yep the different life than us pal
different life they' kill you for
wearing those shoes in their Club I
couldn't wear these if I show up
in I want to beat you up after they're
going to have to take my shoes off I got
to take my shoes off you I feel like uh
you'd be you'd be good they they need
they need big they need muscle those are
my people yeah minus the killing yeah
and drug dealing yeah but like the
chopper thing alleged alleged it is a
club it's a club they do a lot of
fundraising I didn't say that everybody
what the [__] dude Hell's Angels lawyers
boy you use anything of their name and
likeness they're like Mickey Mouse good
luck they'll hunt you down yeah lawyers
you don't want to be wearing you know
the colors unless you've earned them
Mickey Mouse until
recently yeah well the the old school
Mickey but if you do the new school one
they'll come for you don't do Scrooge
McDuck they'll send you a season assist
that's right that's what they did to us
yep yep what else you got Jen this was
the biggest news so far Japan's
earthquakes it was like a 7.6 magnitude
and like over 200
aftershocks so they're still trying to
find people that are trapped but I think
at this point it's going to be is this a
footage of what happens to an office
yeah 2024 coming in so hot man yeah
happened right on New Year
Day Jay was just there dude that's crazy
right there cameraman's filming though
good
balance dedication are you serious
man yeah that's wild so 62 people dead
so far damn Terri anymore and here's
another thing that happened that was
crazy uh an airplane an actual ual
passenger plane flew down to land and
then was it the Coast Guard I forgot
exactly what was the other plane that
was there yeah it was the Coast Guard
they weren't supposed to be on the
runway but they were like kind of
peeking into the runway so they collided
and this passenger plane which has 379
people on board everyone survived [__]
dude everyone survived everyone survived
including the the the passengers and the
you know staff yeah I'll just show you
some of the images
here so that's the plane actually
crashing it's on fire outside all that
fuel looks like a rocket [__] PR scary
man you joking
me damn dude that's got to be hot in
that cabin so all the the passenger
plane you know those people survived but
the Coast Guard I guess the pilot
survived but he was badly hurt and the
five people inside or four people all
died J B it's terrible yeah oh my God
that thing is basally Miracle survive
it's a it's a newer plane they said that
the fact that that there's Japanese
mostly Japanese Japanese Nationals
inside the plane they're very like
disciplined they listen to instructions
you know all that kind of stuff all
added up cuz that that is crazy that's
after I guess yeah they were able but
even when it crashed even when it hit
you saw it like burning up instantly
yeah it's insane that's inside the plane
that's insane it's terrifying
considering what's happening on the
outside this is insane at least they all
got mask on what in M that's another
thing
[Music]
too
wow but that is pretty much a miracle
crazy man oh man all right SAS all right
so been a little beef between Jimmy
Kimmel and Aaron Rogers for a while now
dating back from like the vaccine issues
one proax one's anti and uh
basically yeah you know Aaron came out
and said a couple things Jimmy responded
and then Aaron came out and followed up
with the fact that his name might be on
Epstein's list see I didn't take it that
way I got to read exactly what he said
but I thought he was saying Jimmy's
going to hate when the list comes out
people are assuming he's saying Jimmy's
on the list I think he's saying because
a lot of people that he knows is going
to be on the list and because Jimmy's
hardcore left there's a ton of people on
the left for the record I've not met FL
visit or had any contact whatso with
Epstein nor will you find my name on any
list other than the clearly phony
nonsense that soft brain wacko like your
can't seem seem distinguished from
reality you're reckless go to more jeez
then he goes your Reckless word put my
family in danger keep it up and we will
debate the facts further in court okay
that's that's fair but see I I don't
think aon's saying his name's on the
list I think he said a lot of people
that he Associates with is on the list
and they're going to be out there oh
well that's why I but I let's listen
yeah I'll play the clip and then bring
it 57 and 56 that something to do with
the Epstein list that came out feels
feels that's supposed to be coming out
soon that's supposed to be coming out
soon look this guy's been waiting in his
wine seller I've been waiting in my wine
seller
for a lot of people including Jimmy
Kimmel are really hoping that doesn't
see I don't think that means he's on the
list
people including Jimmy Kim because a lot
of his boys that's not no no no that's
insinuating I'd be pissed off if some
but there's a video before this of
Kimmel talking about you like tin hats
or whatever and kind of putting Aaron
down for fumbling over his words like
about this watch so this is for March
needless to say all this UFO talk has
the tin foil hats going wild including
Green Bay wack Packer Aaron Rogers who
offered this hot take on the Pat McAfee
show I I believe that this been going on
for a long time interesting uh timing on
everything there's a lot of other things
going on in the world did you hear about
The epsteam Client List about to be
released too what's that what are you
talking about there's some files that
have have some names on it that might be
uh getting released pretty soon oh how's
this a conspiracy he's right might be
time to revisit that concussion
protocol this only proves that 's right
I mean he's I mean first of all Jimmy
Kimmel is a comedian he's gonna find
things to make fun of I have no problem
with that well then you can get mad when
there's backlash have no problem with it
no no the problem is when you say that
Jimmy Kimmel's on that list what happens
is he does soat yes you get all these
[__] crazies who are like you [__]
Hollywood let me ask you let me ask you
this though yeah do you think eron
Rogers completely made that up on a whim
what what made up what saying Jimmy
Kim's on the list you think he just
doing that for press I I I don't think
he has any first of all I don't think
Jimmy Kimmel was ever on that list nor
do I think that I don't know who's on
that list I don't know who's on but I
can promise you that that's that is a
you're you're Stern [__] up so cuz cuz I
don't think Aaron knows who's on that
list I don't think he has a clue right
we'll find out and also just because
you're on the list meaning just CU
you're on the flight log and you went
there doesn't mean anything a say that
yeah but I I think Aon if you were on
the list I'd have some [__] question
yes but but but I would have some hard
cold question you just see me in these
shoes and you like oh he didn't get laid
um yeah no I I uh whether you're on the
flight log or you've been there 30 times
there a lot of people on the flight log
cuz they used to have a lot of these
events and parties there doesn't matter
eron didn't say that eron just said you
know what he means no he's Aaron aon's
being a shitty he's being shitty with
that started though whatever the case I
mean I'm just saying that I like you got
to be careful with that stuff because
you can get yourself in trouble you can
get IL legally you can get yourself in
trouble cuz CU with that kind of thing
it does lead to harassment and for sure
and I think Aaron's also kind of being
funny and I think that Jimmy Kimmel's
being funny and I think it's it's when a
comedian like Jimmy Kimmel gets all
bunched up that I just go come on man
you know what I mean why why you're
going after Aaron Rogers there are other
people that go after over Aaron Rogers
is but also but also defense Jimmy
started it right like go look at these
whack conspiracies there's a list like
when you say when you say he should
check the you're making fun of Aaron
Rogers I get it because you're writers
you guys are all together that's an
event he said something on the McAfee
show all good it's what you do but um I
I think that it kind of Falls flat
because Aaron Rogers doesn't have CTE
problems from what I can tell he's got a
very sharp brain Etc smartest people I
know yeah also one of the greatest
quarterbacks arguably to ever do the
damn thing correct so you know it's like
like uh okay all all Aaron Rogers was
saying like a lot of us was there's some
[__] going on not want to see this does
anybody not everybody I know wants to
see this list we want to see it what's
up we all want to see it it's so weird
how long they've been hiding it like the
manifesto in Nashville you know you
should see was the first see that thing
you can see why they hit it this list
you can see why they're preventing it
some of those names that are released
you like in the whole list you think
they give you the whole list oh you you
don't think so [__] no here's what I
some politicians still in in [__]
seat that they can't have on that list B
I I don't want to see the I don't care
about the list here's what I care about
with the within the list I want to see
who's a multiple who's who's on that
flight log 10 and 20 times Bill Gates uh
Bill Clinton yeah Bill Clinton for sure
they said Bill Clinton [__] breaks
right now we're getting into it now
we're getting into it but here's the
thing so if he's on that list he was
[__] if Bill Bill Clint's on that
list 30 times Bill Gates on that list
whatever 30 times but there's no proof
here's what I think so they could be
like we just went for party no no here's
what I think about the EP nothing's
going to happen by the way with any of
this you don't think anything will Happ
shun you get shunned by Society from the
right for a little bit but if you're on
the left you can do no wrong here's what
I protect look at Hunter Biden are you
[__] kiding he'll be going to jail
maybe he any look how long they've been
able to hide it how long have we known
about this laptop 100% they'll protect
them well what I what I think is going
to happen is what I think like I was
with the Jeffrey I've thing I think
Jeffrey Epstein was clearly working for
an intelligence agency and it makes
sense because we don't really have I
guess a forensic Trail on how he made
his money why did Wexler sell him his
mansion a dollar gave it to yeah so this
is the pictures of George Washington in
the house I'm sorry George
Bush think he was that was I think the
island was two things it was a Honeypot
to get very famous powerful people in
compromising positions fil them doing
horrible acts also or just not even that
or just cheating on their wife with some
hot hooker it wasn't just you know it's
not like there were a bunch of children
running around it was it was a lot of
ladies of the evening now some of them
were 17 we find out but some of them
were also 20 and 21 and some of those
politicians probably didn't even know
but they're like hey bud come here you
know she's 17 like what and we got on
film so here's what you're going to do
for us that's how this goes right or or
they just have that if they need it Y
and more importantly it it was also
probably a way for Epstein and the
powers that be to lure very very
powerful men to an island you get laid
you get laid get compromised so he gets
funed or we just talk bus but but
business meaning here's the thing you're
going to donate to this cause if you
don't here's what we're going to do I
don't even know if they were that a
blatant about it I think sometimes it's
like I guarantee I've done you all these
favors you've been on my flight for free
20 times you're getting laid by the end
of these we bring girls in from Miami
and all that you know they were doing
that there's no doubt so so you're
bringing a bunch of like you know
Professionals in there women who are
massaging you and all that [__] and uh
and and everybody's having a good time
and you're talking business you're
getting political favors I think you're
in international waters so a lot of the
[__] you're talking about doesn't apply
there's a whole there was a whole thing
going on this is still going on they
shut down just because they shut down
Epstein's Island somebody bought it but
this is going on elsewhere right now all
money right now somewhere else it's
influence money that's how it goes yeah
and I think probably it would don't you
think it would make sense that someone
like the mad or even the CIA or
whoever's working together are trying to
get you know they're they're trying to
get information government they probably
used other they probably got other
people from other governments there for
sure so the CIA is involved in that too
then maybe I'd love to see the list the
realist not this [__] one we're
going to see what else you got
Jen let's see there we
go okay guys we're going to have a
little team outing soon cuz there is a
fully operated AI restaurant opening in
Pasadena wow everything from cooking to
cleaning like dropping you off yep look
at
it that is weird
weird you can drive your Tesla there we
got to go oh come on that's so
depressing though a't that depressing
yeah no there's just no more Soul into
anything that that's my issue with Tesla
now that's not the engineering Height's
not great there's no soul you know
cooking there's no soul it'll also
though make uh it'll make like you'll
have a lot of restaurants to say we
don't use robots we we use real human
beings and Loving Hands all that stuff
so all fast food is going to go towards
us like Taco Bell Burger King McDonald's
all going to do it you get people eat
cheaper probably more efficient no no
more ISS orders yeah there's no safer
all that [__] quicker y I won't be part
of it but look at
that what about what about meat that's
engineered in a lab that's that's around
the corner won't be part of it yeah you
won't you're not coming to lunch when we
go nope babba in 20 years be like fine I
read the stuff it's just as nutritious
here you go I'm going to have a farm I'm
going to kill myself yeah
yeah so last night I decided to make
soup I wanted to make Italian roleta
soup why waste your time uh well I mean
it just takes a long time to chop things
up clean things you're not a cook I made
a very good soup but but I want to be a
soup I want to be a cook but you going
cook soup dude quit being gay dude well
you want be a chef but you want to just
make especially just going to be soup no
no no I listen man think about this but
dude no just hold on here yeah you
pretend you're tough guy yeah your thing
is soup no hold on dude hold on soup
Teslas and those shoes dude okay hold on
I'm not what is happening I don't know
I'm getting I'm I'm cooking I'm a cook
hold on no soup cooking go to on
Instagram go to curly [__] C R L YF u k
this kid a q this kid was a football
player and I I absolutely love the way
he shoots his stuff and the way he makes
everything looks so good this one yeah
that kid right there 1.4 million
followers now you got a new boyfriend
bubba this kid played football at uh
with the
Badgers um I think it was a lineer yeah
but just keep going go go to the go to
the uh go to that taco one right there
he's very funny can you see Taco one
he's a silly
goose that one right there yeah he
starts by eating it oh there it is
yeah M that's a good
taco
strike
three come on little p of the G come on
start you start thinking a
ah you guys drinking water today don't
lick your lips
now you can't stop watching Bubba M
that's a good taco go to the other just
go
back go
back go down a little bit more I I don't
like cooking stuff I like this kid I
think he's awesome great okay go to that
go to that cheesy one right there that's
Arnold's son right there it is yep watch
this this guy's great that's the best
thing I ever
made watch
B come
on it's a nice looking
loaf Mak you want to eat
dude this that
noise
uhoh well that looks
fantastic that's the best thing I ever
made see what I'm saying yeah man yeah
got Arnold I I didn't see this one with
Arnold yeah watch on your own time so
here's the thing so let me guess you
watch this you start make soup and you
film it for Instagram I'm like do you
film your soup for Instagram no no I
definitely didn't do that I can't do I
can't compete with that but I just was
like I was like this is a this kid is a
genius yeah he's just knows how he just
the editing and stuff and the way he
shoots it and then he's just a good cook
I'm like I want to do that it's how you
become a well-known cook on Instagram
what do you think is that oh I'm in you
you're in I'm in yeah you want to date
that guy I like I mean come on he's
young he's young but he can cook he can
cook we love it neighb he doesn't even
need a shirt half the time it's a stud
that's how you cook fantastic dude I I'm
up up in my game I'm lifting weights I'm
starting to [__] cook handsome kid it
all what else you got
chin oh here you go what's this now uh s
bro resident nice rock star has been
doing all these philanthropy things
lately and he went he was in Melbourne
and he had like an 18-hour shift just
feeding the needy no he always does his
stuff don't say lately no he he's been
doing this for [__] ever he lives in
the valley you see
Shel all the yeah a few weeks ago he
took his big smoker down to one of these
shelters and cooked for 18 hours he do
all yeah one of the salt of the earth
people I love that guy he's so funny too
he such a badass
yep yeah he's amazing and
then talking about teams that have not
had a great season um the Panthers owner
kind of snapped finally and threw a
drink at a jaguars fan I believe he was
Finding about 300 grand for it but that
Fan's going to sue him as well oh yeah
you'll see him in the this a seven
figure mistake he's leaning forward with
the cup right
there like hey dude you're a billionaire
you also this is your fault you put the
Personnel together right you also
drafted wrong
dude he's screwed yeah that guy's
goingon to assume yep Monday Monday
night National
Championship you got to watch that game
Michigan versus
Washington
College yeah Monday night it was
Michigan Bama Washington Texas National
Champion I watch all college you do more
than more than more everybody I know who
likes football watches College more it's
better really I've heard that why it's
just more passion they care more now
they're getting paid it's a little dicey
but it's it's just it's funner they care
more the fans care more and things can
go wrong e right like team's up 20 it's
like you could switch in a quarter like
it's momentum NFL is you're up 20 you're
[__] they know how to play defense
where slow it down force you to pass non
you're [__] they're too good too good
there's not a lot of mistakes yeah qu
good Lu I would watch college I just
don't know the team so I'm not connected
to anything like I root for the the
Cowboys because I know they're going to
blow up but I like d Dak I like Dak
Shepard I like you know I watched I mean
d Dak Prescott and Dak Shepard hat D no
Dak Shepard is AR playing he play a
couple Downs the guy's trying to the guy
trying to cover himself no actually Dak
Shepard I meant it because he's the back
he's the backup he played some Downs
they didn't show I love football Dak
Shepard just doing and Jimmy Kim like
you know corner is just crushing it um
but I but like uh I don't know man
there's I'm I'm like for the example the
Eagles my my girlfriend is her family is
they're such Eagles fans that they sing
the song oh I love that song I know the
whole thing they are [__] nuts about
it and I kind of find myself rooting
against them just because I'm a little
contrarian they haven't been playing
well no they've lost well four the lost
five or something they're crumbling
tough especially right before playoffs
new momentum that's crazy what else you
got Jen here we go Dave Chappelle just
dropped what I would say is arguably his
best special agree in a hot second I got
to see it a hot second cuz usually he's
a little preaching like come on and
they're long this was 58 minutes of
actual jokes and it's great it's so good
yeah best product he's dropped in a hot
second it's so good his take on his take
on Chris Rock The Slap is so good oh it
has a full circle moment right it's
great Andy Kaufman Jim Carrey it's great
man oh I got to see This I Gotta See
this it's so good
yeah okie dokie um think this is the
last one yeah last one uh friend of the
show friend of bees over there Zach
baggin has some sort of doll that's
literally making people faint yeah yeah
like he has stuff in there he's like
don't look in the eyes you know don't
stare at it too long and you get whether
you believe in this [__] or not you're
like this is intense even Rogan went to
the haunted Museum was like this thing's
so I'm telling you it's so legit it's so
good really oh it's legit I'll check it
out I'll definitely
take just fainted from the doll huh or
Hy just
fainted I like
it yeah some of the stuff in there is
intense though super intense bet creepy
I mean people were murdered in the
basement there a oh is that true you go
on the VIP tour you can go to the murder
site it's so intense
really that's the guy that passed out I
can't tell his wife's like come on oh
he's taking care of the guy that passed
out right here oh yeah the guy has your
haircut be yeah he
does yeah is that it J I think that's it
yep Oh no Conor McGregor announced his
fight how are we gonna miss that come on
can't miss that Conor McGregor announced
his fighting uh Chandler at
International fight week midle which is
really weird I'm skeptical of all of it
you are yes I like this I need to hear
more you want to watch the vid just so
you see
video this video is it's so
strange ladies and gentlemen he looks
different right happy New Year to you
all I'd like to announce the return day
for myself the notorious Conor McGregor
the greatest comeback of all
time will take place in Las Vegas for
international fight
week on June the
29th come a little closer and the
opponent Michael Chandler and the weight
Mr Chandler
[Laughter]
[Music]
he's he's so silly it's ridiculous I
think it's really funny go to his last
look he looks go to his last post cuz he
post go that the the one next to his
family no no yeah look at
this he's drinking and look Chandler's
all working his ass off and look at him
he's all hammered drinking it just shows
Chandler just just grinding away Jesus
look at Chandler
[__]
that is
hilarious Conor training absolutely
hammered you think the fight happens um
185 man he one fight at 85 he's never
fought at 85 he's not doesn't weigh 185
right now I doubt I don't think he
weighs he's heavier I think he's lighter
I think he's naturally big right now no
B you got to remember been all those
sauces yeah but even then Bubba he's got
a he's got a piece on him I'm very happy
with his piece yeah that's a big thick
dick yeah but he's got look his legs
Bubba he's still got a small frame he
just does small waist he's not 185 I
promise especially when he's in shape
now now um there but why announce 85 I
don't know is it is it uh is it the fact
first of all that might be a joke that
might be him saying you know that's part
of what he said it I don't know the UFC
would not like that right but what's the
joke in confusing people Santa 85 then
UFC comes out and here's the thing UFC
didn't correct him he's a tiny 85 right
so it's Chandler's short dude short
Chandler would be tough at 70 yeah
Chandler's short agree 100% 85 just no
it makes no sense they're both 55 Conor
doesn't want to well I think Conor start
at 45 his real weight's 45 but the fight
at 85 it just doesn't may and what's it
do for both the divisions like all right
so then let's say chandler wins gets a
win there then he cuts down two8 classes
and fights at 55 decks yeah let's say
Connor smokes him then the next fight's
at 55 or
it all it's just confusing it just shows
you there's not many fights left for
Conor he's going to do this Nate Diaz
Trilogy and then that's it Conor your
[__] toon is showing um I I uh yeah it's
going to be interesting
um what do you think of this fight I I
like the fight you know Chandler
deserves it's been a long time coming I
just don't like the 85 thing that makes
me wonder if it's even happening mhm
seems like a joke which isn't good m and
I'm a huge Conor fan massive Conor fan
but it just shows you there's not if you
would really want to make a run out the
title it'd be at 55 yeah I agree but
he's like yeah we're fighting 85 it's
whatever I don't give a [__] about R
rankings or the belts yeah I don't think
that he's he's not fighting for belt
anymore he didn't care yeah and I wonder
how much you're not going get a win at
85 the UFC's like all right now here's a
shot at makev at 55 it doesn't work like
that no well it might work cuz Connor so
you never know but it'd be weird yeah it
would be medin uh you want to do a
couple more MMA yeah hell yeah let's do
some MMA ones how about just one more
then just give me one good one okay so
Theo had a podcast recently with Sean
Strickland this was Heavy did you guys
watch it yeah it's heavy it makes you
love Strickland I didn't it makes you
absolutely love stricklin and Theo but
you just you watch Strickland you're
like [__] man but this is what Sean no
yeah this is what Sean said so cuz he's
talking about dup polies who said you
think your dad beat you wait till I get
a hold of you which is you know a guy
who comes from Abus
here's the here's the thing with the
[__] talks going on in the UFC today
whether it's
Connor um you know Strickland dupes uh
Jake Paul of the world um Kobe comington
people got to realize that these young
kids this is what they do so we got to
adapt to it the days of man just show
class and just let your fighting do your
talking those days are over no they're
not over they shouldn't be over they're
over and here's why here's why you're 60
so this is you I'm with you I'm I'm to
fight for it as the adults in the room
we have to say stop it don't reward that
here's the thing you don't run the UFC
when Kobe comington made fun of Leon's
fa dead father sales went up
25% so the UFC goes we're a business
this is the world we live in keep doing
what you're doing yeah like I said even
just cuz something works doesn't mean
you do it right and and you can do that
everyone would disagree with you oh no
except for people who believe in common
decency sportsmanship and you know how
to run things and and the reason you do
certain things cheating works sometimes
too in finance you can cheat people you
can actually run scams that is cheating
no one's stealing payview again
pay-per-view buys went up
25% doesn't mean you do it that's all
I'm saying but but again and Conor
McGregor khabib when they did that whole
thing sales went up Jon Jones DC
fighting a press conference sales went
there's a thing about that also that um
that has to be talked about which is it
may work in the short run for you as a
person it's not going to work in a long
run for you as a person doesn't care I'm
with you they should they should realize
like
man you said it a long time ago you said
you said the best thing I'd heard which
was the adults have left the room and as
long as we're there okay got you it
should be on Dana and Ne Brasco guys we
got enough enough right but the problem
is I I think because we're oldheads we
go what are we doing here this too much
you got to realize that Jake paulwood
Logan Pauls Dylan danis of the world
we're used to you know being good
sportsmanship and stuff like that and
that still exists a little bit but no
one Society doesn't care anymore social
media negative does better than positive
y [__] talking when it goes too far
sells pay-per-views so they're pushing
these people to go that direction the
younger audience does not care heard so
we got to realize and adapt and go this
what they do now unfortunately I don't
like it so the problem is that there's
that malakan thing which somebody was
explaining which was you can get a
society can get themselves into a thing
where you get rewarded for being
negative and you can keep getting
rewarded for being negative that's going
so what happens is polarizing so if so
it's not about it's not about debate
anymore it's about amplifying your
monologue and the person that can has
the loudest and the most Sensational way
of speaking is the one who wins you
don't need truth anymore and you
certainly don't need um you don't need
reason what you need is color and you
need English on the ball and all of us
all of us pay a very dear price for that
as a society starts to crumble that way
okay that's why the wise men that's why
the old are there to say hey hey hey you
know and like you said unfortunately the
wise men aren't on Instagram they're not
on YouTube they're not running the UFC
again and look at look at the this is
another thing about technology as Ai and
this is why they're like people like
Elon Musk and stuff are calling for a
global pause on Gene editing like
chrisper cast 9 or on AI we don't know
what happens as all these countries
start competing with everything they
have to out AI each other to out
autonomous robot each other to out
crisper cast n each other by combining
different genetic strains with human
strains Etc we don't know what we're
going to create what we're going to get
right and it could be that is where a
lot of people are saying if you make
machines that smart you might find they
don't have any respect for the biology
that made them and they might you know
these are the things that we start to
get into so it's possible for a society
to keep
competing down not up keep competing
down into hell as opposed to up toward
Heaven that would be all signs are
pointing down yeah which is a shame I
don't condone it but but it doesn't mean
we don't fight it right doesn't mean we
don't keep talking about it agree shame
this article basically um Sean
Strickland saying that there are some
things off limits yeah uh including
talking about a man's wife which you
know the whole Ian Gary Sean thing the
first thing he did was talk about his
wife so so he's learning too maybe
Sean's learning maybe sea changes his
mind maybe Sean goes what's that he just
did that well so what what did uhan resp
out the low is of vile manner but can't
take a p a pinch you attacked my wife uh
andly Conor a pedophile it's clear to
see your childhood trauma showing you
claimed you were giving me advice before
well now it's my turn to return the
favor you should just shut your mouth
focus on the miror because you have
enough serious issues you need to solve
wish you all the best with them don't
ever project your pain onto me and my
family again happy New Year okay so both
of them are actually talking I see
growth with both these guys I see some
realizations well let's see among they
have both have fights coming up we'll
see but but I like your positive
attitude we'll see isn't it interesting
that they're using our platform you and
I the platform that we stand on which is
this the the sportsmanship they're
actually using this to bolster their
argument so that's what's interesting
right they're using it to go attack the
other one that's right okay they're not
using it because they think it's the
right thing to do they're using it but
what both of them are saying is hey
there are
and you went above and beyond with my
family and now they're coming after your
family how's that feel right and so that
that's but let I hopefully they stick to
it yeah but we'll see they both have big
fights coming up dupy's already said his
bits we'll see if duplic doubles down on
it Strickland you know no [__] type
of dude you watch that interview though
and you're like ah man yeah you can't
help but feel sorry for I tell you what
you don't want to do is miss my shows in
San Diego this weekend tomorrow actually
tonight Thursday Friday Saturday mik
drop comedy club I'm bringing heat and
I'm very excited January 4 5 and 6 and
people say you should never book that
close to after New Year's I say it's San
Diego and I say people are going to come
out and I'm excited I think I agree with
you buddy yep CB live Phoenix Arizona
Friday Saturday Sunday doing a Sunday
show okay kind of news to me but that's
all right we'll have some fun and then
Louisville Comedy Club I got February 91
so here we go and I'm kicking off the
keep on Trucking tour this January
January 25th one night at zany in
Nashville only one night two shows
that's January 25th in Nashville that's
a Thursday and then Austin Texas Friday
and Saturday January 26 27th in Austin
Texas at the Vulcan gas Comedy Club all
right Vulcan gas comedy club uh theater
that's so it's Nashville the 25th Austin
26 27th San Jose's February 22nd and
then I'm all over but Nashville and
Austin Europe I'm in Austin again on
January 20th doing fight companion with
Joey Diaz Eddie Bravo and Mr Joseph
Rogan and myself for the big UFC uh
that's Strickland dupes that's January
uh 20th so Nashville then Austin so get
your tickets thick boy.com all right
kids love you Happy New Year 2024 coming
in hot